for more information on tutoring
personalized video solutions or how to
support move university and the
production of more videos check out Mufi
University com
thank you and enjoy okay so in the last
video we talked about how we made the
ketone bodies we made D
beta-hydroxybutyrate but what happens to
the ketone bodies once they get to the
extrahepatic tissues that's basically
what this whole video is about okay so
we've got the D beta hydroxy butyrate
that we made in the liver mitochondria
and now it's in the extra paddock
tissues specifically in the
mitochondrial matrix of them okay so
we're gonna take the D beta hydroxy
butyrate that we made that we're gonna
turn it back into acetyl acetate which
is the other ketone body and in this
process we're going to take this
basically this Oh H group and turn it
into a carbonyl and that is specifically
going to be an oxidation reaction it's
going to be an oxidation and if that's
if that D beta hydroxy butyrate is being
oxidized then something has to be
reduced and in this case it's nad plus
being reduced to NADH you'll notice this
is the reverse reaction that we saw this
is the reverse of the last reaction that
we saw in the previous video and it was
catalyzed by D beta hydroxy butyrate
dehydrogenase so this is catalyzing the
same e the same reaction just the
reverse of it okay so we get this eatle
acetate and previously it was a
reduction right but now we're moving
towards we're going in the opposite
directions with an oxidation so now we
have a seat of acetate what's gonna
happen in this acetyl acetate we're
gonna turn it into acetyl acetyl co a
and in order to do that we're going to
need to add a cleanse I'm a we're gonna
need to add this coenzyme a here okay
and so that's coming from not a CO CO a
actually a succinylcholine which is a
TCA cycle intermediate and so basically
it's gonna give up its coenzyme a to
acetyl acetate and what's gonna be left
over is just the rest of the molecule
which is gonna be succinate again
another TCA cycle intermediates
so here we're basically just taking the
acetoacetate and adding a cleanse I'm a
on to it and this is not base this is
not the reversal something that we saw
in the actual ketone body synthesis this
process is catalyzed by beta keto a SoCo
a transferase also known as thio for ace
I really hope I'm pronouncing that
correctly I'm not sure if there's
another way to pronounce it definitely
let me know okay so what's happening
here is we're getting this acetyl CoA
and we're gonna call that the activation
of acetyl acetate right adding on that
coenzyme a okay now what we're gonna
take that to see the acetyl co a and
basically cut it back up into two acetyl
COAS that we have here okay and so in
order to do that we're going to need a
cleansing that's exactly what we're
gonna add here in this reaction we're
just gonna add a coenzyme a and we're
going to cleave the acetyl coa into two
acetyl COAS that we have here and so
that is a cleavage reaction and if you
had to guess what do you think this
would be catalyzed by if you took a
guess and guess stylist you'd be right
this is a reaction I've seen quite a bit
now at this point okay so now in these
extra hepatic tissues we basically just
made these two acetyl co ways so I the
question down here where is this
happening it's specifically happening in
the mitochondrial matrix of the extra
hepatic tissues okay not liver cells
right why not
liver cells well because the liver makes
the ketone bodies for other tissues
right but also specifically because the
liver does not have beta keto a Sequoia
transferase without forays this enzyme
up here
this enzyme does not show up and ketone
body synthesis right this is not in
ketone body synthesis it's only in in
the in the pathway of using the ketone
bodies as a source of energy right
breaking them breaking the ketone body
down basically back into two acetyl COAS
this enzyme is necessary in order to do
that and this doesn't is not in liver
cells right solar cells can't use ketone
bodies for energy other cells that have
that enzyme can okay and also just just
thinking about it why would the liver
make the ketone bodies and then just
break them right back out it back down
into it so you look away that would just
make no sense right but anyway what
happens so these are pseudo kawaii
these are pseudo as now that they're in
the mitochondrial matrix of these extra
hepatic tissues they can go to the TCA
cycle and of course they will give and
they will give NADH is fadh2s and GTP's
right energy for the cell this is all
energy for those cells
okay so what's ultimately happening with
all this well basically what happened
that the liver is sending acetyl co a
right by way of ketone bodies that it's
that it's not metabolizing it's sending
them to other tissues that will use them
right so we basically took acetyl co
ways that were in the liver converted in
the ketone bodies just said they could
travel in the blood to get to these
extra body tissues and then we took that
ketone body that we started with up here
right which came from the liver and we
just converted it back into acetyl COAS
except now these acetyl co ways are no
longer in the liver right they're in
these other tissues that are gonna break
them down for energy okay now there's a
question though what if those tissues do
not use them what what happens then well
that's something that we'll see in the
next video
I hope that video was helpful thank you
for watching if you found that video
helpful don't forget to Like comment
subscribe and share with friends thank
you and happy studying